if we discovered life on another planet
tomorrow maybe it would change for a
week or two what do you think about the
prospects for the impact on history of a
discovery such as the credible existence
not of just technological life just of
life in general in the universe outside
of Earth the idea that new life would be
benign is one that we must definitely
resist it seems to me much more probable
that it would either intentionally or
unintentionally be very bad for us the
second thing I'd say is that if it were
to turn out to be good or appear good in
the first instance there's plenty of
Science Fiction that tells you it'll
turn out to be bad later so be very
afraid even if they seem nice maybe be
especially afraid but you're right
whatever we discovered would not
radically alter our ways of behavior